press-secretary Kaylee maca nanny held
her second press briefing yesterday you
might remember that Donald Trump's
previous secretary press secretary
Stephanie Grisham held 0.0 press
conferences press briefings during her
entire time as press secretary Kaley
makinen he did one I believe it was
Friday and she did one yesterday now in
her first one she famously pledged not
to lie to the press then she told four
major lies - related to the Russia
investigation one related to ventilators
and one related to Michael Flynn so in
about three minutes
she broke her pledge not to lie
yesterday 12 seconds into the press
briefing she lied by claiming that the
US is doing the most testing merely by
saying we've done 7 million tests of
course as you all know what matters is
per capita in a country of 331 million
people now the last time that we covered
her press briefings I pointed out the
press corps needs to ask her about that
time she went on Fox News in February
and said Trump will never allow
coronavirus to come to the United States
here's what she said back in February
absolutely this president will always
put America first he will always protect
American citizens we will not see
diseases like the corona virus come here
we will not see terrorism come here and
isn't that refreshing when contrasting
it with the awful presidency at
President Obama Caylee mcenamey thank
you so much good to see you thank you
now to his credit Jeff Mason from
Reuters yesterday asked her about
exactly those comments here is how she
handled it she turned to a particular
page in her notebook
she knew the question might show up she
was prepared here's how she addressed it
he worked for the campaign and he made a
comment I believe on Fox and when she
said President Trump will not allow the
corona wire
come to this country given what has
happened since then obviously would you
like to take that back well first let me
note I was asked a question on Fox
Business about presents travel
restrictions I noted what was the intent
behind those travel restrictions which
is we will not see the coronavirus come
here we will not see terrorism come here
referring to an earlier set of travel
restrictions I guess I would turn the
question back on the media and ask
similar questions does Vox want to take
back that they proclaim that the
coronavirus would not be a deadly
pandemic does the Washington Post want
to take back that they told Americans to
get a grip the flu is bigger than the
coronavirus which is the Washington Post
likewise want to take back that our
brains are causing us to exaggerate the
threats of the coronavirus does the New
York Times want to take back that fear
of the virus may be expressed spreading
faster than the virus itself does NPR
want to take back that the flu was a
much bigger threat than the corona virus
and finally once again the Washington
Post would they like to take back but
the government should not respond
aggressively to the corona virus I'll
leave you with those questions and maybe
you'll have some answers what's so funny
about this is that she clearly feels
like that was a huge mic drop moment
where she walks off after turning it
back around on the press it's actually
cringe-worthy and the entire thing was
cringe-worthy she may not last long
because it's it's getting more and more
embarrassing now the trumpet seemed to
be liking it that's what might keep her
in the job she starts the briefing 35
minutes late it lasts only 25 minutes
total
after taking only a few questions she
abruptly walks off after being asked
about a completely laughable ridiculous
thing that she said but the trumpets
love it Donald Don junior tweeted
yesterday saying her answer was fire and
a whole bunch of trumpets are just
thrilled with Caylee Mac and Annie so
let's analyze her argument she said
Trump won't let coronavirus come to the
United States and she responds by saying
listen a lot of media outlets said this
is not going to be a big deal in the
United States that's a terrible argument
number one it's not really an argument
it's actual
the two cuoco a fall as a fallacy which
is the appeal to hypocrisy is another
way to say it which is when you try to
discredit your opponent's argument about
something you did by pointing out that
someone else did the same thing and that
it's it's fallacious strictly speaking
how can the media criticize her when
they said similar things supposedly as
the way the argument goes now first of
all when the media was saying this may
not be a big deal in the United States
the media was reporting what different
medical experts were saying many of whom
were people that were involved with the
Trump administration and so one thing to
understand is a lot of the articles
she's quoting our articles that are
essentially citing the medical experts
that the Trump administration picked to
say things about coronavirus that's
number one it's not like the media
reports when you look at independent and
foreign experts we're not saying this
would be a big deal in fact you can look
at January and February and find a whole
bunch of media reports that are not
based on what Trump affiliated medical
experts were saying if you look at
foreign countries if you look at
independent agencies in the u.s. they
were saying we could take actions that
would prevent this but if we don't it's
going to be a disaster so she's she's
actually wrong about that
and a lot of the reports that she cites
were simply saying here's what someone
associated with the administration says
is going to happen she didn't say here's
what an expert says she simply said
Trump won't allow the virus to come here
so she made a very different type of
claim when she went on Fox News and said
Obama's presidency was awful Trump's not
going to allow it to come here that was
not these are the medical experts
alleging that now secondly none of those
media people who were simply reporting
what was being said were hired to be
Trump's press secretary right the
question about her competence is a very
valid and good question because she was
hired to be Trump's press secretary some
Vox writer who quoted a health expert
who may have been wrong or may have been
taken out or whatever they are not now
speaking for the president but clearly
what she has done is show her hand
she is very much willing to attack the
media she is prepared to attack the
media whenever she gets a question she
doesn't like very much like Donald Trump
does that's what we've learned make sure
you're following the David Pakman show
on Instagram at David Pakman show
we'll be back very soon privacy calm is
one of our sponsors and they're giving
you $5.00 just for using their free
service at privacy comm slash Pakman
privacy's of service I've been using for
a while now I love it it saves me a
bunch of headaches it's completely free
and it's very quick to set up and here's
how it works when you pay for something
online or over the phone instead of
exposing your real credit card number
privacy lets you generate virtual card
numbers the payments are withdrawn from
your checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are
your real credit card number is
protected from the data breaches that
happen unfortunately more often than we
would like
and it's completely free they do have a
paid version with different tiers where
you can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft it costs you nothing and
privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy calm slash Pakman